We live in a world of censorship, right?
But I just want to show you something
that we came across the other day
because we feel passionate about sharing
information and a lot of times a lot of
the videos that we actually will show
and display they actually come from
YouTube. And so um we've we're not you
know this is not our first time getting
censored videos taken down. This
actually is a regular occurrence for us.
But I want to show you something that's
very disturbing
and uh it doesn't make any sense. So
help us to try to make sense of this
right here.
So first of all did did you guys see the
video we did on Christians react to Ask
AmAze?
If you watched that you know there's
some very disturbing material in there.
Where did it come from Scotty? Okay, so
a lot of it came from a YouTube channel
that's called AmAze which is this
YouTube channel right here. And I first
kind of heard about this from um a
couple different sources. Um
there is an awesome YouTuber called uh
Counter Culture Mom and she actually did
a little piece on this and I was kind of
checking out some of her videos and
stuff and I was just like woah what in
the world is this and I started looking
up who else is talking about this and
Ben Shapiro mentioned something about
this and so I started looking into it
because um
I wasn't aware of this website before I
actually investigated a little bit and
then it's a website that's trying to
teach sex education to kids in a um
in their words a um not a boring way in
a very exciting way engaging way which
is which is something that we should do,
right?
This is a topic that we need to to start
talking with kids about.
And so um but it's like stuff like
should I feel bad for watching porn? I
mean
you know these are the things that
they're discussing and and if you watch
this video that we made
uh I mean we'll show you it is pretty
crazy how they are like no you shouldn't
feel bad about watching porn. It's
totally normal and totally fine and it
just goes on and on and on. In fact it's
so disturbing there were some people
that that commented and are commenting
and said they just literally started
yelling at the screen after watching our
video because they were like how is this
even legal to to do this? Ironically we
had to censor
we
put a emoji over the things that were
shown in the videos because they're not
suitable for even adults to be looking
at let alone kids and yet they put it in
a cartoon format. So we censored what we
put on here. Now watch this.
When you click our video and you're not
signed in
So notice how we're not signed in right
here. So in the top corner it says not
signed in. It's an age restriction on
the video that we were commenting on
there's and we even put sensors over the
parts that would be uh more graphic.
Now I do want to say I'm grateful for
this actually because we
we put not for children on the
thumbnail. We put a warning at the
beginning. Scotty mentioned like look
this is not for children. This is for
adults. This is for parents. If you're a
child click off of it. I'm I'm glad for
this.
Ironically though
the website where we got the videos from
that is not censored in any way
you do not have to be signed in. You can
click it
and watch these things fully uncensored.
This is
YouTube bias right here. This is where
So so so look I'm going to click on this
right here and uh we're not going to
actually play the video because
Right here I mean there is already
explicit things on the screen. So
within seconds. The sister walked in and
caught her brother watching pornography.
So they are discussing is it bad to
watch porn? And of course they're like
no it's not it's totally natural. And
then they show well you know this is
what you're going to learn and they show
the the the male completely naked and
stuff like that. So in our video we
we put something over that so you
couldn't see it and look ours is age
restricted. Yet on theirs they can fully
show it. We're not going to show you
because we can't censor it being live.
And uh you're not even signed in.
That's ironic. Don't you think? With
123,000
views now it shows a full male nude
male
and a full nude female in a magazine
and in a cartoon format where children
are going to click this because oh it
looks fun you know colorful cartoons.
Yeah. And there's no age restriction. Oh
let's go one step further. So can you be
a child with a restricted YouTube called
YouTube Kids?
Here's an app called YouTube Kids and
here you see
some maybe not all
but their channel is available to watch
right there.
You can watch on YouTube Kids you can
watch Ask AmAze without any problem.
What do you guys think about that?
Yeah I mean what's going on here? Is
this like
Here's what's interesting to me. If you
guys want I would suggest uh go on to
their website and you can you can click
a complaint.
Click a flag.
I would love to see it if this thing got
thousands of clicks that literally said
hey this material is not suitable for
any age demographic let alone kids and
see what will they do because if we get
one person that comments that and flags
one of our videos with one comment that
says it's age restricted they'll take
our video down. And it's like so I'm
just curious to see if these guys get a
flood of people that don't like their
material would they actually take it
down?
can you can click the three dots go to
report
which I will
proudly do. Sexual content
uh is actually harmful and child abuse
but they're only going to let you select
one.
So maybe we should select child abuse or
sexual content. Let's do sexual content.
And
uh nudity nudity graphic sexual activity
as well.
nudity.
So time stamp? Oh well
it up. You might have to turn the camera
away.
[laughter]
I will. Yeah.
But I think yeah [snorts] You want to
show the three dots again? I didn't I
wasn't close when Okay, so they're
they're right here.
If you click the three dots next to
share save three dots that's where you
will see an option to report. Make sure
you find the time stamp
for where the nudity is. It's in more
than one place in this video.
It would be
at 33 seconds in
and also 50 50 seconds in.
So it's at 33. Yep.
Ironically 33. Yeah, right.
As well as
one second in.
So while he's doing that I just want to
comment on this. Um we feel very
passionate about sharing this
information and this is not for shock
value. Um really when we sat down and
and we kind of did this topic um if any
of you guys have watched this this thing
um we really just wanted parents. I'm a
parent. My have a a 9-year-old and
11-year-old and you know they're around
uh uh other people with technology or
you know my phone my wife's phone uh
there is internet in my home. And uh we
try as best as possible to
tell our kids they are not allowed to
just pick up the device and go on the
internet. We monitor we know what
they're watching. We we we try to teach
them there are things on the internet
that they actually should not be paying
attention to. And so that was why we
wanted to do a piece like this. We
wanted you guys to know like hey even
YouTube just simple YouTube is not
always just a safe environment for your
kids to just thumb through and those
suggestions can come up. So you know we
really thought about this as we decided
to put this project together and we said
you know we don't want to expose people
to something needlessly but you guys
need to be aware that we are in the end
of days here and stuff is just getting
out of control. I I feel like this is
like modern day Sodom and Gomorrah. I
mean this stuff is just getting worse
and more degraded and all that and if
you're not aware of it then the devil
can easily just slip something in the
background and and it can become a
problem with a child. So if you have
young children please prayerfully
consider like you know just talking
about safeties and and how to guard your
children and not expose them to these
kind of things and uh you know I'll
apologize if I if if you can just
playing this on our ministry video
platform is exposing people to it
needlessly. I I want to be the first to
say that was not our intention. Our
intention is really to speak to the
parents. That's why it came with a
warning and um we hope that you guys
were aware of this kind of a thing and
then you can um adjust your parenting
styles or skills to what you feel is
appropriate for them.
There are some comments here. People are
actually having issues reporting the
video. Some are saying the report button
isn't even there to click. I mean that's
not shocking. Yeah that's that's not
really shocking actually.
[laughter]
But Thanks for trying. That's our call
to you right now like go do that right
now. We got 115,000 subscribers. Imagine
if all those people reported this junk
this garbage.
Maybe maybe it'll be taken down.
Yeah or put an age restriction on it. I
mean if you really want you know like to
put this information out hey if you put
them 18 plus, then
you know, whatever. I wish it would just
all go off of the internet, but you
know.
And if you're not going to age restrict
this, why age restrict us who have
censored it and are trying to
share some insight on this.
People are asking what's the name of the
channel again?
Ask Amase.
And I do want to say it like this, too.
Um
some of their
more popular videos, obviously, are are
dealing with sexual topics. They're not
all like that. There is probably some
good
information mixed in there. I mean,
that's exactly how the devil works. He's
not going to serve you straight poison.
There is some positive things with, you
know, them talking about the science of
whatever, males and females and stuff
like that. So,
they are trying to be educational about
it, but some of the educational aspects
are are disturbing to me. Telling a
young child that that pornography is
totally okay or you can masturbate as
many times as you want in a day. I have
a problem with that. I think that's
inappropriate to tell a child that. And
so,
um you know, I I'm sure some critics
could easily say, "Well, they're not all
like that." Yeah, but the ones that the
kids are watching are terrible, terrible
topics. So, if you look at their most
their most um
mostly watched, viewed ones, then a lot
of them have these very inappropriate
things. So, even if they have good
scientific information on it and it's
way down at the bottom, chances are
there could be kids that jump on here
and only see one or two of these videos
and never get a proper context of that.
So,
A new thing is interesting that the one
that says masturbation totally normal,
you have to be signed in, but if you
watch the very same video in Spanish,
it's not it's not age restricted, so
not sure why or in another language.
So, here is the same video
in another language.
Not age restricted.
And it shows the same stuff. I mean,
you see.
Yeah.
Not age restricted.
But I'll tell you, you know, I have a
huge soft spot in my heart for children
and I I believe that a lot of the
problems that we have in our adult life
stem back and have their roots into
things that either happened in your
childhood or you were exposed to in your
childhood. And so,
um I believe that it is our duty as
parents to guard those those young souls
that God has entrusted into our care.
And so, to thrust them into an adult
world without the proper context of A,
the reason why sexuality was even given
to us humans through a godly perspective
of a marriage between a man and a woman
and and the the context of the the
psychological effects and impacts that
that has upon people, to just literally
tell them about the mechanics of it and
then how to not get pregnant.
Uh I have a problem with that. And so,
you know, I think that these things if
if at best they won't take it off the
internet, you should put a warning on
the beginning of this. This information
is not, you know, necessarily agreed
upon by all people or something. I don't
know. It's just just to kind of throw it
out there is is I think problematic. Is
it normal to watch porn?
So, this is not age age restricted. And
there's, you know,
Yes,
it's normal, I say.
So, we see a huge problem with that.
When we had Check out the video, the
testimony of the guy who used to record
porn. He used to work with Ron Jeremy.
He talks about all the horrible things
that happen behind the scenes. You think
it's just
some video that you can watch and enjoy,
but it's not. There's a lot of people,
real life people who are having to do
terrible things and living a life of
exploitation and doing things that they
don't want to have they don't want to
do, a life of drugs just to continue
doing this job. This Doing this, saying
yes, it's normal and it's okay to watch
porn, you're supporting sex trafficking,
you're supporting
uh child pornography a lot of times.
These girls lie about their age. You're
supporting
just the exploitation of of people. So,
it's not good. It's not normal. And
there is so much scientific evidence of
the damage that, you know, a lifestyle
of engaging in watching pornography does
to you, your marriage. I mean, we've
heard story after story of marriages
breaking up and, you know, it's just
it's just there's no good story that
ever comes out of that. So, to put that
out there to a child and tell them, you
know, this is okay, you can go ahead and
do this, you are setting that child up
for a lifetime of problems down the road
that their marriage may fall apart, they
may have, you know, a wild you know,
experiences and things that that could
put them into danger and I mean, it's
just
there's never a good story about this.
So, please prayerfully protect your
children. And parents,
there is there is a time that we need to
appropriately give the child proper
contexts and understandings of
sexuality. So, pray about when it's
appropriate to talk to your kids about
that. Do diligence. If you don't feel
like you have the right words to be able
to to give to the child, God will help
you. He will give you the right words to
put it in frame it in a godly
perspective so that that child gets the
proper information first because I
guarantee you if they're around friends
and things in some point of their life,
public school, public school, they're
going to come across this information.
And so, you want to beat the world to
that punch and give them the right
perspective. So, when they hear the
wrong perspective, they'll go, "No, no,
no, that's not what my my parents told
me about it." And so, um prayerfully
think about how to do that. And um I
believe you need to come up with a plan.
Thanks for watching. Thanks, guys. We
love you. We'll see you next time.